oui merci isabelle pour ce qui concerne
les français de l'étranger la question
était simple et la place des français de
l'étranger aux sommes au sein d'un
mouvement
je vois juste rappeler une chose que
peut être vous avez déjà oublié
malheureusement le président de la
république qui a créé le secrétariat
d'état des français de l'étranger que
j'ai eu l'honneur d'assumer avec ensuite
edouard courtial
c'est nicolas sarkozy voilà répond ce
qui était demandé depuis des dizaines
d'années a été assouvie lors que ce
quinquennat deuxième chose
le président qui a permis à ce qui est
des députés des français de l'étranger
au nombre de 11
c'est aussi nicolas sarkozy alors je
peux vous dire que la place des français
de l'étranger au sein de notre mouvement
elle est primordiale elle est majeure
parce que il est bien évident que
lorsqu'on va lorsqu'on est en train de
construire un projet pour la france en
2010 est en particulier nos meilleurs
experts pour savoir ce qui marche ou pas
à l'étranger dans les pays dans lesquels
ils vivent
c'est bel et bien nos amis français de
l'étranger qui sont aujourd'hui des
républicains dont leurs plats salés là
vous êtes des experts nous attendons et
pour tous ceux qui se présentent aux
élections
nous leur souhaitons bonne chance et
votre vos contributions sont les
bienvenues